I do not suppose to know everything.
And those closest to me, they might say,
I don't really know much at all, but --
One thing that I know to be true
beyond the shadow of a doubt is this.
The surest way to fail in life
is to set a goal.
(Laughter)
Now, unfortunately, I found this out
through excruciating pain,
but hopefully in the next nine minutes,
I can convince you, too,
that this is true, without the pain.
Unless, of course, you consider
listening to me painful.
OK.
The year was 2011.
I was seeking to become
a multimillionaire by the age of 21.
So how was I going to do this?
It was simple.
I was going to leave college
at the University of Texas
one year early.
I was going to leave after my junior year
and declare for the National
Football League draft.
In order to do this, however,
you have to submit your resume to the NFL.
A resume in football,
it is your highlight tapes
from your years playing prior.
So I submitted my football tape
from my freshman,
my sophomore and my junior year.
The NFL sent me back a letter.
It simply read,
"Dear Emmanuel,
you will not be drafted
in the first three rounds."
Excuse you.
I won't be drafted
in the first three rounds?
So what did I do, TED audience?
It's simple.
I set a goal that day.
But you know what they say
about goal-setting.
You've got to write it down,
commit it to memory.
So I highlighted the sheet of paper.
“Dear Emmanuel, you won’t be drafted
in the first three rounds,”
and I put it above my bed
in my condo in Austin, Texas.
Every morning I woke up, I looked at it.
"Dear Emmanuel, you won't be drafted
in the first three rounds."
Every night before I went
to sleep, I looked at it.
"Dear Emmanuel, you won't be drafted
in the first three rounds."
I worked tirelessly
my senior year in college
with one goal in mind.
Be drafted in the first three
rounds of the NFL draft.
Those are the most prestigious
rounds after all.
6am workouts in college,
study hall, class.
I'm doing it all, with one goal in mind.
Well, fast forward one year later,
I'm at the NFL Combine.
The NFL Combine, it is the job interview.
I'm in front of 32 billionaires.
32 of the richest men in America,
if not the richest men in the world.
They are the owners of every NFL team.
I'm running the 40-yard dash.
The 40-yard dash is one of the testing
metrics you use at the NFL Combine
with millions of dollars on the line.
The faster you run,
the higher you get drafted.
I take my mark.
I proceed to run.
I hear pop, pop, pop.
I keep running.
I think my heels are clicking.
Pop, pop, pop.
I clutch my quad, I fall to the ground.
It was my quad being torn off the bone.
(Audience: Oh!)
I ripped my quad off the bone,
I’m falling [to the] ground in agony
in front of these 32 billionaires.
I didn't get drafted in the first
three rounds of the NFL draft.
I made a decision that day,
in that moment,
to stop setting goals.
My self-esteem, ruined.
Self-efficacy, ruined.
That last year of my life
seemingly gone to waste
because I had one goal, y'all.
It was simple.
Be drafted in the first three rounds.
Then I tore my quad,
and it all fell apart.
What I failed to mention thus far
is why I tore my quad.
Two days prior at the NFL Combine,
I weighed in at 240 pounds.
In the NFL, the bigger
you are, the better.
But as you all know, weight,
it don't move all that fast.
So I cut 10 pounds within two days.
I ran the 40-yard dash
two days later at 230 pounds,
dehydrated, dieted for two days.
Why? Because I was so focused on my goal
that I caused harm to myself.
It's not that goals don't add value.
It’s just that the risk of goal-setting,
it is greater than the potential reward.
Think about it in your own
life for a moment.
Maybe you had the goal
of being in a relationship.
So you ignore the toxic behavior.
Think about it in your own life.
See, one of my greatest
accomplishments to date,
being an NFL player,
because ultimately
I did play for four years,
I view negatively
because I didn't hit my goal.
Maybe that's the same for some of you.
Maybe you have the goal of reading
a certain amount of books in a year.
You've become a much more proficient
reader, but you didn't hit your goal.
Maybe you had a goal of making a certain
amount of money for your business.
You are a thriving entrepreneur,
but you didn't hit your goal.
I left the NFL.
I became a content creator
where I would live
a much more limitless life.
I'll get to that more here in a moment.
The question now is why
in the world do we set goals?
Well, first, let's define a goal.
A goal, by definition, it is the end
towards which effort is aimed.
But why would I start something
with the end in mind?
In working on my master’s degree
in sports psychology,
I focused on goal-setting,
I wrote my final thesis on it,
and I realized we set goals
for three primary reasons.
The first.
We've been indoctrinated with this belief
that we have to set a goal to achieve.
There's a popularized study,
which has since been debunked,
which said the person
who writes their goals down
and commits them to memory,
they will earn twice as much money
as the person who doesn't.
So what you want me to believe
is the difference
between one million dollars
and 500,000 dollars is this?
What you want me to believe
is the difference between 100,000 dollars
and 50,000 dollars is simply this?
Can't be.
Now, these ideas
aren't completely off-base.
The problem is very simple.
They're misidentifying
causation and correlation.
Surely there is a correlation
between the person who was willing
to go the extra mile
and write their goal down
and the person who's willing to go
the extra mile in their business.
But no, the reason you're making
twice as much money
is not because you wrote your goal down.
The second reason we set goals,
goals give us a North Star.
Motivation.
As if we'd just be wandering
around life aimlessly
if we didn't set a goal.
The final reason we set goals?
We have this insatiable
desire for feedback.
And feedback,
it is a predecessor, is a necessary
aspect of goal-setting.
Think about it in your own life.
Did this Instagram post get as many
likes as that Instagram post?
Did this tweet get as many likes
as my last tweet?
How about this TikTok post?
Did it get as many shares as my last?
We have this insatiable
desire for feedback.
You know, I made a mistake earlier.
I said the surest way
to fail in life is to set a goal.
But in all honesty,
the only way to fail in life
is to set a goal.
Think about anything
you've ever failed at.
Maybe relationally,
occupationally, educationally.
That marriage, it ended in divorce.
You didn't get into that college
that you wanted to.
You didn't pass the MCAT,
you didn't pass the LSAT,
whatever the case may be,
it was all tethered to a goal.
It's not just that the surest way
to fail in life is to set a goal.
The only way to fail in life
is to set a goal.
So what do I suggest we do instead?
Here it is.
You have an objective with no limitations.
Now I know what you're thinking,
Acho, that's semantics.
No, this small difference will have
a huge impact in your life.
Objective: effort aimed in a direction.
A goal: the end towards which
energy is aimed.
Your objective, it should be subjective.
It should be subject
to people's interpretation.
That way you do not fail.
The theme of this conference
is Possibilities.
You all have spent money,
left your homes, maybe children,
because somewhere deep down inside you,
you subscribe to this notion
of possibility.
But you can't simultaneously subscribe
to the notion of possibility
while still being held captive
by goal-setting.
The laws of goal-setting completely
undermine the freedom of possibility.
So if we're being honest with ourselves,
we have to choose one.
Because possibility is limitless.
But goal-setting, oh,
it’s fixated on an end.
If you want to have
a 10-million dollar business,
you'll set that goal.
And you might do just that.
Have a 10-million dollar business.
Congratulations.
You'll work towards
a 10-million dollar business.
But what if it could have been more?
If you want to run a mile
without stopping,
you’ll work towards it,
and you might do just that.
Having never known
if you could have run a marathon.
What does it look like practically?
Kirk Hammett, lead guitarist
for Metallica,
he never had the goal
of winning eight Grammys.
He never had the goal
of selling 125 million records,
never had the goal of being a rock star.
He simply said, and I quote,
"I just want to play my guitar
a little bit better every day."
Close quote.
See, because with that, there is no end.
A goal, by its definition,
it is focused on an ending,
which means inherently a goal is limiting.
It's not that goals in
and of themselves have no value,
it's just, what about the damage
you have done to yourself,
your self-esteem, your self-efficacy,
the way in which you view yourself
when you look at yourself?
What about that damage?
I'm not saying don't achieve.
I'm saying achieve limitlessly.
I'm saying believe in the reason
you were all sitting in here today
because you believe in possibility.
Let go of the captivity of goal-setting
and achieve all
you actually have to achieve.
So what is my objective
with no limitations?
Very simply put,
to be considered one
of the most creative people
the television industry has ever seen.
Because if I would have achieved my goal
of being drafted in the first
three rounds of the NFL draft,
I never would have achieved this.
Winning a Primetime Emmy Award
and sharing that moment with my mom.
(Applause)
But just as importantly,
if I would have achieved my goal
of being drafted in the first
three rounds of the NFL draft,
I wouldn't be standing
in front of you all today.
Why?
Because if you hear nothing else,
truly, if you hear nothing else,
hear this.
I'm begging each and every one
of you to hear this.
The goal that you achieve,
it's actually the penalty that you receive
for having set that goal
in the first place.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)